hi I'm hauntin from Microsoft Research
Asia and I want to talk to you about
haptics today we've all had the
following experience it's cold outside
so put on my gloves go outside the house
take out my car keys and I want to open
the car door with my remote I cannot
feel the buttons on my key because I'm
wearing a glove so I looked down take a
glance at the buttons press on it the
door opens the fact that I cannot feel
these buttons does not bother me because
I could always look at that key and find
that button and execute a price now what
if I tell you this is exactly how we
have been interacting with our computers
we touch that screen with a gnome hand
but we cannot feel anything other than a
piece of code glass with developing
technologies that's going to enable you
to not only touch but feel that computer
screen what we have done is we want to
create a sensation when you type that's
much more similar to a key click not
just an abstract sound not just an
abstract vibration so we do this by
taking the screen actually literally off
of that phone and put piezo-electric
materials under the bezel now when you
have a keyboard you're typing on the
phone that glass literally bent
instantaneously very small bending but
that's enough to tell your finger that
if you like it click this is our surface
touch cover except it's only a cover we
have taken everything outside and put
different things in there again we use
piezo electric actuators so when I send
a high voltage to it they buckle and
that is the mechanism for creating that
sense of click under your fingertip and
we find that people do type faster
and they make less errors when they can
have this kind of key click as compared
to just sound feedback which is
typically implemented in most of these
devices let me move on and talk about
feeling things on the screen so here i
have a checkerboard on a Lumia 920 phone
the black part feels a bit sticky and
the white part feels smoother now we do
this by putting a piece of glass on top
of the phone and we again use the
wonderful peers or electric actuators on
top of that piece of glass and we
vibrate that glass at very high
frequency this way up and down but what
happens is when you run your finger on
that piece of glass it can trap a very
small piece of air between your finger
and that screen and this is what makes
the screen feel smoother the last demo
is very similar we change surface
friction also you can feel different
regions as different textures but we do
this with a different mechanism we call
this electrostatic haptics the finger
tip is filled with fluid here so when
there's charges here it attracts the
opposite charges towards them so that
creates a force that post the finger
down now when you move your finger back
and forth I can fool people into
thinking that something's happening on
that piece of glass I hope that we've
given you a glimpse into the future of
human-computer interaction where we can
not only reach out and touch but feel
what's on that computer screen thank you
you